it was a big year for the gays and we
can't do a show around here without
talking about the gays of course Prop 8
was struck down gay marriage just in the
last couple weeks passed in or
judicially has been passed now in Ohio
and in Utah but of course not everything
was perfect because duck dynasty yeah
Phil Robertson the I guess of the Ducks
well take a look and the first thing you
see is gross sexual they just one of
their bodies with one another degree is
that going on yes actually Phil it is
this is a free country we're allowed to
do with our bodies what we so please
okay so as you all know a well ane let
me just real quick a and he suspended
him of course everyone went nuts he got
reinstated it had nothing to do with the
First Amendment that is the point cuz
everyone kept saying in First Amendment
I was watching Greta Van Susteren on Fox
News going on and on with Rick Santorum
that the First Amendment is under attack
Steve you explain why it wasn't a First
Amendment issue please you're a lawyer
the First Amendment proscribes the
government the government not a private
entity from preventing speech and and
there are you know time place and manner
restrictions so for example at TYT i
could i could pass a rule that says if
you say the word hamburger you're fired
that's not a that's not an infringement
of free speech right if i mean i could
pass a rule that says you know what if
you vote democrat you're fired if you
actually that that might be a problem
but if I say but if I say the new rule
if you if you sing you're fired whatever
it may be that's not a violation of our
freedom of speech it's not it's only
when the government comes into play so I
don't want to get too hung up on the on
the free speech issue but isn't this
exactly what happened him being
suspended at first then making some sort
of we're a pro-lgbt company so we're
gonna suspend you then the market
dictated that he came back because they
realized they were gonna lose a lot of
money isn't this exactly how it should
have worked
I don't I mean I guess it's how it I'm
not defending the guy I know you know I
just think it's funny that he said they
degrade each other with their sex and
degrade each other is there anything
more degrading than that beard are you
kidding me look at the way you dress do
you really value yourself
I don't think so to have you over the
last time he was to a dentist I think if
he really valued himself he wouldn't be
worried about where other people are
sticking their penises and maybe he
would get cleaned up and put on a nice
jacket that's all I'm saying
okay so thank you we're all cleanly
shaved today very day thank you very
much it is pretty badass jacket and but
hehe but it should so that's what I said
people people said to me why should
I'm tired if someone says something and
they automatically get fired speech
somebody said this to me and I'm like
well first of all you have to take him
on a case-by-case basis right so I think
what Paula Deen did was much less worse
than what Donald Trump did yet Donald
Trump gets to keep his show on NBC so I
think you have to go case by case so
what I'm saying about this duck dynasty
guy is that if you work at A&E if you're
at work and like if you're a producer or
senior producer or marketing guy how do
you now work for that show how do you
promote that guy who is promoting hatred
against gays with a Y yeah so but isn't
this how the system should what the
market yeah hated what happened I xx
agree with you Dave I think it's exactly
that it worked out so Annie if I'm a
Annie if I'm an executive there I would
think well this guy said very hateful
things so this might hurt our bread just
I hurt at the bottom dollar so I'm gonna
suspend him and we'll figure out what
what we should do and then there's a
huge backlash and people like no we want
this guy I'm okay
he's back on the air right it's a lot of
money yeah and look and that's what
that's what corporations are supposed to
do they need to maximize profits and if
you don't do it guess what happens you
get fired right so recently the the the
the CEO of Hyundai Motors he got
replaced even though he did a great job
for like three and a half years the last
six months not so great gone okay that's
what happens in any any private
corporation with respected this
particular guy so a lack of are very
offended by his comments and I find his
comments hideous actually the part that
was the worst would even break that
wasn't even yeah I was just throwing an
exercise cuz we've seen all the yeah the
part way talks about like what are you
gonna do Pennsylvania it's kind of
secure it's scary stuff and he's holding
that weird like torture like stubbly
left hand it's all creepy and I mean I
think as far as like anti-gay commentary
and inciting violence against gays this
is as bad as it gets it I've ever
personally seen all that being said if
he has a show duck dynasty on A&E and
he's not saying those things on air I
don't I mean I don't like it I don't
watch the show but I don't feel this
need to go on a crusade to get it off
the air yeah yeah I've never in any of
these things Alec Baldwin or Paula Deen
I've never advocated for any of them to
be fired because they can say stupid
[ __ ] and then we can make fun of them
for it that's that's what America's well
but they do get fired and then it's not
like a violation of free speech you're
not going to jail yeah I mean people can
fight people all the time for it's just
a calculus that you make as a as a TV
exact okay I can't just make two yeah
really quick is I don't understand why
religious because that everybody came
out and offended duck dynasty guy based
on he's just religious religion it says
written what about favor religious
religion to hate other people and to
preach incendiary hateful things against
other people that's what Jesus did right
so that's what they keep saying and I go
for religion is always couched in
hatreds always yes so you can use
religion of course we know this they use
religion to justify slavery they use
religion to justify every war there
everyone so they use religion now to
justify hating gays right and
persecuting gays and marginalizing them
and
keeping them from getting equal rights
why is it that if you're religious do
you get a pass for being an ignorant
backward [ __ ] why do you why do
religious but all these realities the
bishop Oh easily live till he hates gay
so that's ok but let's have them all
forget no [ __ ] you
you're ignorant that's backward thinking
and it's not ok to say it's your
religion then you realize that isn't
that what the KKK could say just my
religion this is what Jesus they think
they're all Christian too so and my
other thing was when Alec Baldwin you
know he's called the guy a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and he said that he calls him a
[ __ ] Fathead right right because
he thought the [ __ ] part was the bad
part and but but of course he said
because no one says that [ __ ] and
then said nobody says you [ __ ]
fart snorkel well you say you keep it
consistent with the dirtiness of the
words okay look I've ever watched duck
dynasty I don't know if it's a good show
or a bad show now if you are a fan of
the show that's fine you can like to
show yeah but you don't have to like
everything about that guy and once you
find out that the guy is hateful in many
ways there's no need to worship Him
there's no need to run to his defense to
have either pins I mean I just don't des
apart that on get these fanatics who are
so angry that people are upset by his
comments they're very upset upsetting
comments of course you should be upset
like OJ Simpson I was a I see a big fan
of him until we found out he probably
most likely murder brutally murdered two
people that I'm not as much of a fan
anymore as part of that though that we
have these groups these advocacy groups
like in this case GLAAD and the HRC that
they have to do it like what if they
don't jump on it then what are they in
business for right no no well I mean I
think they should I thought what the
fingers of the challenge none of the
fans of the show who are so angry that
people are upset by Phil Robertson's
comments I'm like why are you angry
about that you should be angry too you
should be upset by those comments too I
mean so I I love I love you know sports
and I love I love the show
modern modern family if I found out that
the guy who pays Phil Dunphy ty burrell
yeah
he's a horrible misogynist and and talks
about raping [ __ ] all the time I
would have a real problem
I wouldn't say well I love Tiber I love
the show therefore everything says I'm
okay with that too I want people to
separate the show and the actor and all
of that from what they do in their
private life and if it's bad you can you
can not like that person it's not a big
deal i can i can i can still enjoy Annie
Hall even though I find Woody Allen
personally be reprehensible I can tell
you Jewish yeah Boyle - cheers yeah
that's what I'm talking about also
married his daughter mean Oh what Mel
Gibson didn't say anything about that
last thing on this what do you make of
the connect majority we have in the
country that Amin
these people all think that they're the
ones being persecuted and it's like you
know what no gay people are actually the
ones that don't have equal rights if
you're a Christian in this country of
course you have equal rights there's
nothing you were denied as a Christian
but there is true day there's a warrant
Christmas boys are persecuted at every
turn the the atheists and the gays and
the Jews had they've all the power all
the power I went out I tried to buy my
wife a Christmas present the stores were
all closed on Christmas I want to I want
to buy a Christmas present like no you
can buy this but not for Christmas
that's what they told me was really
weird it's the oldest trick in the book
right so then if you watch Fox News and
the rest if they're always the victims
right and it's just funny that the
dominant culture sees themselves as a
victim somehow to the minority culture
which is the way they've been playing it
out and it's good it because it riles up
people who don't think deeply and they
gets them to hate people they need to
hate so they can push their agenda if
you ever hear someone use a word
wickedness disregard everything that
person says versus a clown who says the
word wickedness right and let me just
can I say two things you got it that
duck dynasty guy is fighting same-sex
attraction there's no doubt about it
there's no doubt there's no doubt about
that guys fight because no I'm telling
you if there's anything I know for sure
is that straight guys don't give a [ __ ]
about what gay guys do with their
penises they don't give a [ __ ] it's only
the guys who think they might like it
that makes them uncomfortable that they
have to go I don't want you to be able
to do that and I think you're a horrible
person and by the way if you read up
about duck dynasty guy he was a mr.
crazy drug addict [ __ ] in the 60s
and 70s so he was this he was the exact
thing he's railing against and that's
always how it is the silent silent
sinners always scream the loudest so
whenever I see somebody publicly
moralizing I know that guy is doing
something with his penis
that he feels bad about